very serious question today okay when
did you find out thinna was what six
years old I was six maybe around six or
seven the freshman year of high school
so I'm for like a very traditional
family like a very church don't like
Hispanic family and they basically like
kept it really secret for a long time
and they were really good at that so she
was like come on I gotta tell you
something and we roller skated to the
top of the coal decide we sat down on
the curb and she leaned over and she's
like I was like what and I was
devastated and I was reeling and I was
looking around going I can't believe
this and then she said and the Easter
Bunny too and I was like what and it was
the worst angry moment of my young life
it was and then I used it every time I
got mad at my parents I would be like to
my little brothers and said oh I was
horrible just like one time I did that
and then I realized like I was going
straight to hell for that but I know
that was it it was that was rough lies
lies but in our family our let's say to
this day
Santa keeps coming as long as you
believe so you know I still believe in
Santa Claus I was maybe around six or
seven and my older sister and I cornered
my mom like mom we know that Santa's not
real she's like what are you talking
about we're like
sin is not real just do me just a minute
she's like okay you're right Santa's
real and I just started bawling I was
not ready for a restaurant and as Santa
was there and he pulled down his beard
and I saw that yesterday when I was 4
years old and I caught my dad eating the
milk and cookies that I put out for
Santa I was heartbroken because I
specifically made those cookies for
Santa and he able he made the excuse
saying that sounded taller than me to
eat them and then my mom was just taken
already and yeah that's when they told
me Santa's not real mommy and daddy buy
you presents I cried a little bit but I
was ok afterward I think I my dad never
let Santa be room for me so I think I
always in the Santa wasn't real Peaks
plays Santa has a marketing tool to make
money so that's kind of what I've always
been a standard corporations are you
know businesses are try to put this
image of Santa in your head like Oh
Santa's
yes it makes you want to like fulfill
that need for your kids to have gifts
you know see go out and buy gifts or
whatever and then Santa you know in
movies in the industry the high
Hollywood but there's been so many Santa
movies you know they use center to make
hey Santa sent his elves the reindeer
all that Christmas when my mom and Santa
have the same wrapping paper in the same
handwriting I kind of put two and two
together that they are the same person I
was probably like nine my brothers were
talking about it with my mom but Santa
wasn't real and they just assumed I knew
and they asked me if I liked court I was
like yeah course he's not real
but I was heartbroken I never thought
Santa was free he'll cuz I'm foreign so
no one told me about Santa it was just
your parents got you guys and you know
it's really weird 300 man breaks into
your house gives you presents kinda
creepy but it's love it probably like
two years ago when my grandma's like
haha so what'd he offer Christmas and I
was like I don't know what's gonna get
me and then she was like
what do you mean and I was like what
what do you mean and she's like oh oh
they're mine and I was like okay and
then yeah that's that's kind of rude
19 I was like I was like 16 I was like
16 years old and then like she kind of
like do it so yeah all right so my mom
she messed up she didn't tell me but she
we left cookies out for Santa and I
found him in the toilet so she didn't
eat him and she didn't flush the toilet
so she left the evidence and then I
started doing detective work and I put
two and two together and that's when I
knew the president's kept rolling in so
it was cool and at that point I was
already getting a little older like I
should have known but I was oblivious
now kids know I'm sure they know a lot
sooner because of the internet maybe on
YouTube looking stuff up so Christmas is
kind of ruined I think the YouTube
comments section
don't not too bad but I think it's a
pretty good place to go you oughta be
devastated
Brittany Christmas time my family likes
to have a little sense of therefore like
all the cousins and nieces and aunts and
stuff so one of these years I was just
like I think that looks like my cousin
Victor and I pretty much just knew from
there I found out something was wrong
one day I saw my mom with his big black
trash bag and the piano board that I
wanted accidentally stuck out so I've
been lying to me this whole time I was
at my family's Christmas party and it
was my uncle that normally dressed up I
obviously didn't do this but I went out
into the backyard to like go get
something I don't know what I was doing
but I went out and he was getting
dressed and like I was like he's getting
dressed he's like what are you doing
back here that's the moment I was like
crushed so I went back to the party like
well how'd you feel betrayed my life is
alive it's like heartbreaking I was so
mad at my mom for like years still
getting over it actually I'm pissed I
was pissed as hell I'm pretty bummed
yeah you know I would be sad devastated
but it's okay
it's just a growing moment a growing
moment in life as often times things are
when they're not as they appear to be
I think he Israeli guys my name is Raya
and I'm the owner of this channel I'm
also the person behind the camera and I
thought I'd take a minute to thank all
the subscribers I gained so far and
maybe ask the new year's to hit the
subscribe button if you liked this
episode or if you're fans with my
channel in general a lot thank you